okay we're here on overtime with Paul
bagalla Democratic strategist Kristen
sulcus Anderson was on our show tonight
and counter-terrorism Doctor Malcolm
Nance was at the front of the show now
we're on CNN I can't believe they're
still doing this for this but I'm glad
we're here on CNN and as I said last
week if you don't watch this what
happens is people write things you know
I don't even know what these questions
are but I'm going to ask them this is
for you Malcolm how much longer will the
American public tolerate our involvement
in Ukraine well I think they're more
than tolerating and I think they're
pretty much Foursquare behind it most
people aren't they yeah we're absolutely
behind yeah and uh we're going to
tolerate it as long as we can uh feel
that we're upholding the Democratic
Values we established in the world for
the rest of the world I mean we'll give
up I mean did we give up in the Civil
War do we give up in World War One World
War II who put up with it I mean it's
not like going to Burger King we gave up
in Vietnam
no we didn't give up but we you know
I'm slacked off as far as our war we're
a country of good tolerance right all
right uh for the panel does the fact
that Sarah Huckabee Sanders is a is the
fact that this is written badly that
Sarah Huckabee Sanders is a nepo baby
to detract from her political
accomplishments I guess they were
hearing me talk about the Huckabee
Dynasty but yes that's a big uh saying
these days nepo baby you know what that
is it's like they mostly refer to people
in show businesses no but anybody who's
mother or father was a star and then
you're a star that makes you a nepo baby
I could name many of them they're very
upset about being called that my I've
noticed this phenomenon forever as many
people have out here and I was it's fine
if you're if your parents were in Show
Business just don't say as I've heard
some of them say well it wasn't any
easier for me yes it was
it was easier for you or the other thing
they say a lot is uh well it just got me
in the door well that's a lot of it in
Show Business is getting in the door
anybody can act it's not that
hard oh
sorry I forgotten when you're in
politics sorry CNN I know I forgot we're
not supposed to not on HBO now when
you're in politics one of the things
that you want generally is higher Name
ID when a poster like me goes out and we
do a survey we want to know how many
people know what your name is at all and
if you have right or increasingly a mom
that has been in politics before it does
make it easier for voters to just go I
liked her dad George Bush you know the
second
that guy when he ran he he went to the
top of the polls and I remember this
story I think in 1999 the people thought
it was his father
that's what they were responding to he
had the same name and they thought oh
George Bush is running again right he
was a one-termer he could do it and and
Franklin Roosevelt's cousin Teddy was
president before him John Quincy Adam's
dad was praying before I mean there is a
tradition of that in America but you
still have to I I don't support Governor
Sanders I don't know her I probably
wouldn't even like her but she earned
that job fair and square she won the by
the way she didn't we didn't cheat
nobody cheated it wasn't rigged she won
the election fair and square and she's
entitled I think to the respect that a
governor of a state I noticed that she
she made a big point of age she said
yeah Biden is 80 and I'm 40. by the way
I thought she was 60. but okay
I I was shot no I'm not 60 but I was I
was shocked that she was only 40. I mean
Washington has a way of taking a toll on
you let's just leave it at that but I
mean that was kind of a strange thing to
brag about I thought I don't think it's
a strange thing to brag about especially
if your core argument going into 2024 is
that Joe Biden has passed his Prime and
we need to do something new now this it
depends upon does the Republican party
not nominate someone who is also
approaching 80. and so that's why some
people that's what you're talking about
something that I thought was very
interesting about her response is she
talked a lot about a new generation of
Republican leadership and when she
talked about her time working for the
former president she did not use the
word Trump once yes and I understand he
was pissed yeah okay uh Public Schools
saw 1.2 million students depart during
the pandemic and many have turned to
homeschooling are we in the midst of a
public education crisis
yeah I saw that today in the paper also
a lot of the students who went away
during the pandemic never came back
what do you make of that
I
school is good Community Education
Community Education is good because you
have to develop social skills the
hardest part about school is like recess
and gym and all the times you have to
interact with all those other little
ten-year-olds so I think it's really
important for kids to be back in school
I do too but I mean well it can create a
physical problem for a school too so
most schools the way they get their
funding is how many kids are enrolled if
all of a sudden your enrollment Falls by
five or ten percent your funding Falls
by five or ten percent so the fact that
public schools for so many parents they
said I don't know if I trust this
institution to educate my child anymore
it's also going to potentially make the
schools worse or have to do more with
less when that student funding is now
gone and and also I mean you say you
think kids should be in school it's the
Democratic party your party that is
blamed for that not happening during the
pandemic right and it happened
Republican states and Democratic states
and they all those things were doing the
best they could with the science that
was available but there were some
Ezekiel Emanuel is a Doctor Who's
advising Biden was saying at the time
this is going to hurt kids we should be
really careful about closing schools uh
and I remember Zeke saying that so it's
but I don't want to bang on people who
were trying to save lives when we lost a
million people at stinking virus we're
still losing 5 600 a day but it was it
was clear much earlier on than many
Democratic leaders in particular
Republicans didn't put them back in
school either they did they did a lot
faster and that's
yeah I mean I think the Republicans
would say that it was the teachers union
which is very strong and democratically
controlled that made sure that the
schools did not reopen and also that
you're not it's not the kids who were
dying from it right and that's the big
shame is that the kids who were getting
hurt the most by it were the ones whose
parents don't have the resources to say
well the public school's bad let me take
them out put him in a private schooler
sure I can homeschool them I have the
bandwidth to do that it was poor kids
kids of color they're the ones who have
seen the biggest learning loss as a
result
uh Malcolm
if the cops who killed Tyree Nichols had
been white would be see would we be
seeing a different response
you know I'm afraid to say that we would
have I mean I think that we would have
had a slow walk of the indictments uh
but you know the issue here isn't about
the color of the policeman the issue is
that the tactics techniques procedures
and training of these law enforcement
officers on these special teams uh you
know way back when I went through a SWAT
officers course with Capitol Hill Police
and some other police forces that were
there to learn how to be SWAT cops the
techniques that we were shown back then
were not always guns forward guns all
the time now the average police officers
is trained to believe that he's you know
number one job is to come home at night
I agree with that a thousand percent but
there are jobs there there are things
there that are just clearly require an
intervention that does not require you
to draw your weapon yeah I mean this
this doesn't I mean that certainly
everything you said is valid all that is
an issue this seemed to be just five
cops who wanted to wail on a guy for no
apparent reason
it if if that kid had been white would
they have not done that no they wouldn't
have period we all know that so five I
mean there is a color there there is a
color issue within law enforcement
altogether even among black Congress
yeah because they're cops because
they're cops this is a mindset the same
way we have in the military we have a
mindset right uh I think policing now
has moved so far away from community
service towards self-preservation uh you
know they they go to courses like the on
killing program on how to do
self-preservation how to battle like a
you know a special forces Soldier what
they need to do is they need to start
thinking more along the old Beat cop you
know protecting the community by knowing
the community and not seeing I don't
understand it right I'm a big guns guy
not every black man is the one who has
the firearm right they assume this block
is all armed maybe that's because some
of them are but I'm going to tell you
there is a large proportion of the the
white population in the United States
who routinely carry guns openly Brazil
you have stickers on their cars and cops
just see oh these are the kind of guys
that I go to range with good job oh can
I just Kyle Rittenhouse for example
right right they gave through him water
that night if I had been out on the
street with a long rifle like that they
would have been throwing uh lead down
there Freedom bullets at me right okay
um for Paul said
should Biden should Biden do the annual
pre-super Bowl interview on Fox oh yes
he that's a tradition and Biden is
turned it down or or as has been done by
other presidents yeah why did he why do
you think he declined that it raises the
all-important question who cares I'm
sorry he has no obligation to get foxes
I just don't care I guess I'm always on
inclined to communicate more not less I
guess if I advise him I'd tell him to do
it but the fox is not entitled to the
time of the president United States of
America I'm sorry they're just another
Corporation trying to make a buck
uh
Kristen what do you make of Ron DeSantis
installing a conservative anti-woke
board at the new College of Florida
so he has made a big name for himself as
being someone who is pushing back
against what he views as an education
system both K-12 and high red that's
gone too far off
I don't know that the answer to Liberal
overreach in higher ed is conservative
overreach in higher ed so I'm much more
interested in when I'm thinking about
higher education in Florida my home
state is I look at the University of
Florida where Ben sass was just
installed as president there were some
protesters but not as many on the day of
his actual installment and he has really
said I'm not coming at this with an
ideological lens he is certainly
conservative himself but can he take an
institution and actually do interesting
things with it that are not about owning
the libs or about proving this is what a
conservative school is like this is
something that frustrates me about the
right is every time they see something
on the left that they think they've gone
too far we need to create a conservative
version of it let's have conservative
Wikipedia that's a conservative Twitter
it's just it's always it's just silly
why not just try to thrive in these
institutions and do what you can to make
them work for everyone from within
perfect sense I love it thank you very
much thank you folks thank you CNN sorry
about it I went one more one week when I
say the bad word
[Applause]